Francine I actually like to start with a
very basic question that I don't know
the answer to we have these IMF World
Bank meetings what are they what comes
out of them what's the result hi David
this is basically a massive gathering of
minds what comes out of it we may have a
communicate will probably have several
does it really focus on the things that
matter probably not we're not going to
have a communique about currency wars
we're not going to have a communicate on
China but this is a gathering of
probably some of the most important
people in the world we have 200
participants central bank governors
finance ministers and there's also the
g20 participant so there you go in
little meetings David and we try and
figure out by following them and by
interviewing them really what they worry
about the most and also whether they
have any answers to our many many
questions about China so do you have any
sense at this point what they are
worried about what they're talking about
the Fed China commodities what are they
talking about yeah so they're talking
about all of that David the feds
certainly on everyone's mind because
there's a belief that of course when the
Fed Starks hiking interest rates it will
of course her emerging markets so now
when you speak to some of the emerging
market participants and I spoke to the
south african central bank governor he
says yes of course if the Fed delays the
interest rate hike it means that he
himself has a better handle on the
economy because he has rampant inflation
which is due to the rand the local
currency of course sliding by a lot at
the same time that the economy is going
pretty badly so he has a policy
conundrum if the Fed delays it makes his
job easier but he says there's this over
hanging uncertainty David and this is
what he wants to get away from he says
you know the Fed just go ahead and do it
so the emerging markets at least know
how the market reacts this is a very
different view to the IMF they say look
there's absolutely no point in the Fed
let's taking it you know let's say
putting a gamble a because of domestic
inflation not being there but also the
impact that it would have on a lot of
these emerging markets that are very
dependent on commodities and you know
that's not been doing
well John you are responsible for a
number of sovereign and international
institutional relationships for
Blackstone do you pay attention to this
meeting um no I because I don't have
time you know I look for there for the
summaries I look for the key themes i
will look carefully at what the IMF
director christian the guard says in
terms of trend-spotting and people like
zoom in and people like that what having
said that having gone to these meetings
many times they're really an important
forum for people to put their thoughts
together on very detailed issues and
it's probably not of interest to this
group at this panel here but there are a
group of people who find these things
very interesting well we're going to be
following what Francine Lacroix is
covering down there and leave up
Francine so thank you very much for
joining us